الى ملف من لبنان هذا البلد الذي يعتبر
على نطاق واسع بلا ذنبراليا بالمعايير
الاقليميه حيث تلعب المراه دورا بارزا في
الحياه العامه هناك هو بحسب دراسه صادمه
العادات والتقاليد والعرف والعرض تشكل
المجتمعات حاجزا بالنسبه للسيدات في
المجتمع اللبنانيه دراسته لمنظمه ابعاد
تقول ان اكثر من نصف الاعتداءات الجنسيه
في لبنان تبقى طي الكتمان وعليه تضطر من
تعرضت للعنف الجنسي لكتمان الامر حتى لا
تصبح ثقلا على كاهل عائلتها وصمتها
ومن هنا وان صارت وكشفت الفتاه يحيط الخطر
بحياتها رينادريه والتفاصيل
حمله لبنانيه لردع الاعتداء الجنسي في بلد
تتهاون قوانينه في معاقبه المغتصب
العرض والشرف هاجس يمنع ست من اصل 10 نساء
تعرضنا للاعتداء الجنسي في لبنان من
التبليغ عن الجريمه ما يعني ان اكثر من
نصف نساء لبنان لم يبلغ
نا ان المجتمع يرى ان الجريمه بدرجه
الاولى تشكل اعتداء على عرض العائله قبل
ان تكون اعتداءا ونفسيا على المراه
سنه 2022 يعني المراه صارت ضحيه ضحيه عم
يغتصبها وكمان ضحيه
القانون اللي ما عم يحميها
عيب على اللي عمله وبدها تحكي تنقدر نخلي
غير ضحايا ما يكونوا بذات الموقف عنا
ونقدر نلقط الشخص وما نخليه بالشارع قاعد
عم يمشي كانه ما صار شيء
الارقام هذه وردت في دراسه اجرتها منظمه
ابعاد الحقوقيه التي نجحت قبل اعوام
بالغاء ماده قانونيه كانت تعفي المغتصب من
العقاب في حال تزوج من ضحيته تحت شعار
الابيض لا يغطي الاغتصاب
وكان جرائم اعتداء على العرض او على العرض
او جرائم اعتداء على شرف اكثر ما هي جريمه
اعتداء على جسد المراه
وحريتها وارادتها ومن هون المطالبه بتشديد
العقوبات لا تصبح العقوب بحجم جرائم هذه
الجرائم كبيره ويجب ان تكون لديها عقوبه
بيت كبير لمنع التكرار مثل جرائم وحمايه
النساء والفتيات
عقوبه بحجم الجريمه مطلب موحد جمع نساء
الناجيات من الاعتداء الجنسي ونشطات امام
مجلس النواب اللبناني تتوسطهم عارضه
الازياء والمؤثره اللبنانيه نور عريضه
للمطالبه بتعديل وتجديد العقبات على جرائم
الاعتداء الجنسي لصباح العربيه رينادويه
بيروت
[موسيقى]
الهدف منه اقرار اقتراح تعديل جرائم
اعتداء الجنسي وتشديد العقوبات بحجم جرائم
مش العاب والعار انه يحكوا لعيبه العالم
انه يكون في اغتصاب هيك وما يكون في عقوبه
من وراءها
[موسيقى]
دائما المجتمع بيحكم على المراه لانه
عملت هيك لانه لبست هيك
[موسيقى]
على كل تنظر من هنا من بيروت امنه خليل
المشرفه التقنيه في قسم حالات العنف
الاجتماعي اهلا بك يا امينه نورتنا في
صباح العربيه شكرا على تواجدك معانا لو
انت عارف اول هل لديكم اي احصاءات عن
الاعتداءات الجنسيه وهل بالفعل العديد من
الاعتداءات تبقى طيب
صباح النور
شكرا
نحن حاليا بايطار حمله 16 يوم ل ااا مناظر
لعندكم على النوع الاجتماعي واكيد في
احصاءات تعمل لنا اياها اكيد
طلعنا بمخرجات لهذه الحمله
اذا بتكون هيك نحكي اكثر احصاءات عن عن
موضوع التحرش الجنسي والاغتصاب همم
الدراسه اللي عملناها اعطتنا نتائج همم
بين معنا ست من اصل 10 سيدات همم تعرضوا
للاعتداء الجنسي بس همم ما بلغوا عن هذا
الاعتداء بسبب مبدا اساسي ولا اللي هو
العرض والشرف همم والعار مثل ما بينقال في
عندنا خمسه من اصل 10 نساء كمان تعرضوا
للاعداء الجنسي بس كمان ما بلغوه لانه
عائلته رفضت التبليغ بسبب كمان العارض همم
والشرف اللي همم
اوتر التبليغ
في عندنا سته من اصل كمان عشر نساء
اتعرضوا بناتهم للاعتداء الجلسه وكانهن من
الاشخاص اللي رفضوا كمان يصير في تبليغ عن
الاعتداء بسبب نفس المبدا اللي هو العرض
الشرف فاذا بتلاحظ اذا بعطيكم كل الوقت
احصاءات راح يظل فيه عدم تغيير
امنه نحصل الامور ونفهم اكثر بدقه عندما
نتحدث عن كلمه اعتداء جنسي يعني تحت اي
كثير يمكن وضعها اولا يعني اتحدث عن
التحرش نتحدث عن اغتصاب
اعتداء تحرش لفظي ماذا
بس نقول اعتداء جنسي هو يشمل التحرش
الجنسي يشمل محاوله الاغتصاب او الاغتصاب
هو اي اي سلوك اييي يتعدى المساحه الخاصه
بالسيده ومرتبطه
الاحتمالات او التصرفات الجنسيه طب ما دام
العداد كبيره
من الابلاغ عن هذه الحالات
للاسف للاسف نحنا بعدنا بيبي اه مثل
بلدان الشرق الاوسط اذا بدنا او دوللنا
العربيه اللي بعدنا بنعمل وصمه على الناجي
او على ضحيه الاعتداء الجنسي ومنربط
الموضوع
[موسيقى]
العار او او راح نعمل فضيحه رح نعمل يعني
نربطها باسم العيله بكيان العيله اي
اعتداء جنسي هو مرتبط
بالعائله كنعان كلها مش بانه هي حادثه
فيها ذنبه وفي عقوبه عشان هيك التبليغ راح
يوصل السيد بمجتمعنا لانه كثير هي موضوع
اتهام مش المعتدي لكن امن يعني
لبنان مع غيره من الدول العربيه يعني
لبناني يعتبر نوعا ما في انفتاح اكثر
مساحه اكثر من الحريه من غيره من البلدان
العربيه همم من ناحيه الليبراليه والتعبير
من حيث جسد والمظهر وحتى في الاراء
السياسيه يعني كمان هناك كيف نفسر هذه
الظاهره بانه في اكثر من 60% من سيدات
لبنان لا يقومن بالتبليغ عندما يتعرضنا
الاعتداء جنسي
صح لا شك انه نحن عاملين تقدم كثير كبير
في ما يحك او في ما في ما يتعلق
همم
التوعيه عن الاعتداء الجنسي واثاره
امكانيه التبليغ وكيفيه التبليغ والوصول
همم للمحاسبه بس همم اللي بيقدر اقوله
اكثر انه هي هي باكتش هي همم توعيه هي
انون تغيير سياسات قانونيه تعديل قوانينيه
معينه همم تستدعي يصير في من بعد عقوبات
همم وهي نظره مجتمعيه فعشان هيك اذا ما
مشينا امباراللال مع بعضهم كلهم راح يضل
في شيء ناقص وراح ضل همم القدره على
التبليغ اقل فعلشان كده همم الحملات عن
تنعمل منظمه ابعاده من قبل كمان منظمات
اخرى او جمعيات شريكه لحتى نقدر نواعي
ونقول انه فينا نكون عم نبلغ نحنا عم نعمل
شراكه كثير الامن الداخلي تيقدر يكون
بالحديث
قوى الامن الداخلي امنه هل هناك قوانين في
لبنان تحمي ضحيه الاعتداء الجنسي
همم اللي عم نساله انه نحن عم نشبك مع
الكتل النيابيه حاليا لحتى نقدر نحصل على
ال ال التوقيع يلي بيساعدنا اكثر بانه
نلزم ويصير هذا القانون
يتماثل او او يكون بينفس
[موسيقى]
وقع الجريمه لانه الاعتداء الجنسي هو
الجريمه بعد المحاسبه هي اقل من الواقع
هالجريمه ف احنا عم نسعى لحتى ناخذ همم
الموافقه نيابيه او لا نقدر نشرع او نقدر
نساعد بيتعديل هذا القانون تفسير المحاسبه
فعلا
العربيه لانه
المعتدي عندما يفلت من الحساب يتمادى نحن
نشكرك جزيل الشكر من بيروت امنه خليل
المشرفه التقنيه في قسم حالات العنف
الاجتماعي